okay i'm just as confused as you guys
are right every source of information
that i saw said that ethan hawke was
playing randall spector and then the
subtitles for the trailer basically
confirmed that he's playing arthur
harrow uh and so i'm i'm suspecting here
that a lot of you guys are probably
wanting me to make a video about arthur
harrow now here's the thing we'll do a
character explanation on this guy but
this is one of those instances where we
do a character explanation that's
basically covering a story because this
guy only ever appeared in one comic and
then he was never seen or heard from
again um a lot of this was because of
the fact for those of you guys who were
who you know really recall a little bit
of the discussion that we did when it
came to randall spector yesterday that
during moon night volume 2 it was really
more of like a mini-series than anything
else that it was basically an attempt by
marvel to kind of reinvigorate the
character of moon knight which kind of
worked depending on who you're talking
to but issue number two is basically the
story that gave us the the events
surrounding arthur harrow and so what
this does is this initially picks up in
the northern yucatan right that
basically in this mexican forest what
you have uh is this guy who just kind of
or really these guys that just sort of
descend out of the water carrying the
bodies of other people and that where
you have these these bodies that are
that are sort of brought in that they
kind of refer to their leader or the
person controlling them as master who of
course you know these guys confirm that
nobody had seen it right nobody had
caught them and this guy basically says
okay like these are these are great
specimens and ultimately the motivation
behind this guy kidnapping these people
is that they will basically serve the
purpose of helping him cure himself of
his illness right this kind of agonizing
pain and and what he describes as
grotesque paralysis of his face of
course this guy is basically arthur
harrow and that what they've been doing
is going around and essentially
kidnapping uh laborers right just sort
of doing it uh indiscriminately but also
with huge gaps in between so seemingly
nobody is aware of the fact that these
people are going missing and so what you
end up doing is basically switching over
to mark spector right where you know in
the city of new york where mark
spector's doing mark specter stuff right
things you do when you're a man that has
multiple personalities and you have a
difficult time differentiating who is
who uh and of course there's some girl
that's basically being harassed and he
ends up getting in a fight with this guy
throws him out the window and then
realizes he can't swim so of course he
jumps out basically saves this guy's
life and brings it back and then
suddenly he's met by the arrival of
marlene now marlene and mark spector had
always kind of been on again off again
right that marlene allen is basically
the girl that was with mark spector and
in fact the daughter of the initial uh
archaeologist that mark spector was
supposed to was really hired to protect
alongside wild bushmen when bushman
basically shot the archaeologist and
left mark spector for dead and then
mark's body was taken before the
egyptian god konchu and then he was
resurrected and then went on to become
moon knight uh and so their relationship
was kind of forged in this fire of
conflict and struggle but they were
always sort of on to get off again at
this point in time their relationship
had basically been over uh and mark
spector had essentially moved on but of
course running back into her again is
kind of like okay like you know like we
need to talk or have a conversation of
some kind and he ultimately ends up
chasing her down now it's one of those
things where he's trying to understand
that does she hate him like that kind of
a thing right trying to at the very
least get his bearings on where she
stands with regards to the two of them
but as she's racing away he basically
ends up you know jumping into his
vehicle and then is suddenly met by the
priests of konshu now the priests of
khanshu are these guys that as far as
i'm aware we haven't seen for quite some
time and in all honesty they're not
really necessary anymore but the idea
behind the priest of konshu is that with
the egyptian god himself they served him
for about 5 000 years before mark
spector ever met konchu at all so they'd
been around for an exceedingly long
amount of time the way this would work
or at least the way it worked here is
that the the priest of konshu would
appear to marx spectre and then
basically say kanchu has a task for you
or there is something out there that you
need to do that you need to take care of
as an avatar of conscious on earth right
they would basically be his alert system
that there was something that was needed
or something needed to be done if it was
in a general vicinity that he was
unaware of so they were by all standards
of measurement plot devices but they
effectively appear to him and then give
him a kind of telepathic vision of
arthur harrow this giant pyramid the
experiments arthur hero is engaged in
and a mysterious woman and so their
their whole the whole response is you
have to go to yucatan and you got to
figure out what's going on and so of
course with all the money that mark
specter has at his disposal using the
identity of steve grant he basically
shows up at this really really swanky
and fancy resort and then of course this
mysterious woman that he had a vision of
suddenly shows up here at that point he
takes off and then basically dons his
moon knight costume so if you guys are
or kind of if you if you're not really
getting a sense here this very much
follows the old 1970s 1980s comic book
format right like this this gives you
very much vibes from like the old adam
west batman days that kind of a thing
right okay like my mission has started
time for me to get in my costume and
find out what's going on right you know
that that's sort of the thing and so
what ends up happening is that with this
woman she's actually being followed and
once mark spector has donned his moon
knight costume she's basically kidnapped
and tossed into a van of course this
leads to mark spector chasing them down
and then of course you know jumping on
the van that kind of a thing and really
engaging in a little bit of a fight here
not a whole lot doing right just kind of
getting into a little bit of a conflict
facing off against these guys
incapacitating all of them and then once
they're defeated he crashes into a tree
because mark spectre can't drive and so
what this does is it leads to a
conversation between himself and this
woman now this is particularly
interesting because what this does is it
has heavy vibes based on the future
stories that we would see in marvel
comics specifically with marvel presents
weapon x right and we'll talk about what
that means here in a second sort of
bringing that history together and how
it all sort of unifies but what ends up
happening is this woman basically
introduces herself as dr grail right
victoria grail and that what's going on
is she's basically here to kind of
investigate what's taking place she has
her own assignments and her own things
that she's doing but when mark spector
says like i need to know who the who the
disfigured man is victoria grahl is kind
of surprised to know or surprised to
find out that he's aware that moonite is
aware of this particular guy that she's
investigating and she's tracking but
what she reveals is that this guy arthur
harrow is actually a candidate for the
nobel prize in medicine that he
essentially drew the attention of the
nobel prize committee and then all
they're really waiting on is for him to
kind of come out with this information
and saying like i found a way to cure
pain right i found a way to remove pain
from the human body so that people can
sort of go forward and live their lives
pain-free at least those who struggle
with it chronically the big issue that
victoria grail has here is that the the
speed at which he's been able to achieve
these levels of success these huge
milestones in his experiments go beyond
the public information he's put out
there which is that he's using animal
experimentation that because of the fact
that he's basically found ways to crack
pain receptors in humans that what it
looks like is he's using humans as
experiments and he's doing this in the
yucatan because it allows him to
basically kidnap migrant workers and
then nobody really seems to be aware of
the fact that they're gone not only that
she's actually traced the information
that he's gathered back to auschwitz
basically using these old world war ii
german experiments on human beings now
here's the reason why that matters when
it comes to the events that were taking
place in auschwitz specifically this all
deals with mr sinister right so as you
guys know of course world war ii
concentration camps auschwitz different
things like that that one of the things
that had gone on in marvel comics is
that nathaniel essex was actually
obsessed with cracking the human genome
and understanding the x-gene itself
right why is it that some people in this
world are born with like the ability to
achieve telepathy or things like that
but those powers don't really manifest
until they go through puberty or some
state of high duress and that world war
ii was the perfect place for him to
perform these grotesque experiments
without anybody asking any questions now
a lot of the research that was done by
mr sinister was actually taken by
individuals and used for the post-world
war ii weapons plus program which
ultimately led to the introduction or
the creation of wolverine so it's how
all this stuff really kind of ties
together but the important thing is they
basically end up tracking him down uh to
his base of operations right this
pyramid that he's operating out of and
in truth when you switch over to arthur
harrow himself he's really saying that
like his main motivation here is to cure
himself and he says like they didn't go
far enough in auschwitz the war's end
interrupted their brilliant work right
and that now he's basically continuing
the work that was initially started
during world war ii so very much just
kind of abandoning logic and reason and
this is very much turned into an
obsession or perhaps that's who he
always was we're never really given
enough information to know if that's the
case but in injecting the serum into uh
into the sky what he realizes is that as
he cuts him right as he damages his
tissue there's no wincing right none
whatsoever that is true immunity to pain
so he's basically achieved the the goal
that he's been hunting for all he has to
do now is find a way to synthesize it
but in the middle of all that he's
basically met by the by the activation
of a video screen that belongs to a
group called omni now we never find out
what this organization stands for all we
know is that it's one of the many shady
organizations that exists out there in
the world of comics that's seemingly
funding the research of of arthur harrow
right basically allowing him to do what
it is that he needs to do the other part
about this is that arthur harrow has
actually grown extremely frustrated with
omnium because at the end of the day
their funding of his research largely
seemed to be conducive on him performing
his research under their terms saying
that like in the end that once he's
found his cure that omnium will no
longer dictate terms to arthur harrow
right it'll basically have the upper
hand on him seemingly what's going on
with this organization as shady as it is
is that they're funding the research of
arthur harrow so they can in turn take
the research of arthur herrera and
probably find some way to to
capitalize on it right to sell it to the
general public and some kind of miracle
drug or something along those lines but
once victoria grail and moon knight get
to their location of course back in
these early days mark spector's powers
were enhanced so he was given super
strength and things like that whenever
the moon was out and of course they
would be amplified whenever there was a
full moon and so at this point here
while it looks like it is a full moon
albeit a little bit shrouded by the uh
by the the clouds and whatnot then
ultimately it grants him the strength he
needs to literally start smashing down
steel doors and different things along
those lines now of course this whole
thing is basically being watched by uh
by arthur harrow who unleashes a jaguar
on them i mean the jaguar's not really
going to do much against moon knight and
of course mark spector is able to uh to
overcome this guy and then ultimately
ends up finding what looks like
basically a secret passage where he
literally smashes the door down or
smashes the wall down with a desk him
and victoria end up descending into this
underground cavern where there's all
these people that have been experimented
on by arthur harrow that are really more
zombies than anything else right they
they are they're what you would consider
to be lobotomized but they follow orders
right so they don't they're not really
able to think on any higher level and so
they're basically told by arthur harrow
kill those guys right and then arthur
harrow essentially bails out right just
takes off now of course because of the
fact that these are basically innocents
they're a result of you know grotesque
experiments at the hands of arthur
harrow then ultimately moon knight
doesn't really beat them to death the
reality is that his life is put in
jeopardy by one of them but because of
his strength he's able to overpower this
guy the reality is that when it came to
moon knight he never cared about killing
people right like he would kill bad guys
it's one of the things that
differentiated moon knight from
seemingly all the other superheroes that
existed in marvel comics right he was
just pretty extreme and in fact the
extreme nature of moon knight was one of
the big sources of contention between
himself and the rest of the avengers
when he was a member of the avengers
team but of course once all these guys
are basically overcome this leads to
moon knight and victoria basically
grabbing one of the steel doors
literally ripping it off the hinges
which is really kind of insane but the
problem is that once they get to where
arthur harrow's at he's basically on a
helipad waiting for the arrival of the
helicopter and then there's a massive
explosion that goes off is a trap that
was set by by arthur herro he ascends
onto the helicopter and then leaves and
that's it right that's all you really
get following that he basically arrives
at what looks like the base of
operations for omnium and they basically
say like we will continue we'll help you
continue your experiments right like i
mean this is just a little setback
you'll continue in some other location
and that's it you never see or hear from
arthur harrow again after this in marvel
comics he's gone forever right like
that's basically it but this is arthur
harrell explained right such as it is i
mean this guy appeared in one comic uh
he was a guy who was a nobel prize
candidate who was
performing experiments on people
ultimately one of his places where he
was experimenting on people was
destroyed or really you know discovered
by moon knight and his campaign was
ended there only for him to move to
another location and continue his
research right so like that's it this is
all you get
which really kind of begs the question
why would marvel use him in moon knight
probably because the guy's so obscure no
one's gonna care if they totally change
around the entire basis behind his
character i mean i'm sure people who
know who he is now and are more comic
curious will kind of use this as a
reason to like be angry but at the end
of the day like no one cares right i
mean it doesn't really matter the guy's
obscure enough the mcu can get away with
it but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace
you